I like to be very competitive I'm
competitive I'm always competitive we
will compete competitive you have to
compete against other people competing
with yourself who you're competing you
want to win
hello belief nation today we're going to
talk about how you can be more
competitive as usual if you hear
something that really resonates with you
make sure to leave it in the comments
below and put it in quotes so other
people can be inspired as well when it
comes to winning in business I like to
be very competitive I like to pour
boiling oil over my competitors and
think every day how can I kill because
that is the war of business ultimately I
want my shareholders to make more money
than my competitors and that's very
healthy so I think the DNA of a business
has to be how do you make money how do
you spend your time making money for
your shareholders and your nobody is an
entrepreneur until you've made money for
somebody else I'm competitive
really with myself right
honestly like every time I start an
album I go and watch all of my
performances and I try to figure out
okay what is it that I could have done
better or what worked and really my
references I go back to myself and try
to better myself so I'm really tough on
me more so than than anyone else I'm not
a competitive person that walks in
thinking about other people and how I
can compete with them more especially
not my husband everybody wants to
compete I think it's knowing how to
compete and also you know I
we don't from competitive instinct
really kicks in when you're down you
know like I said a lot of people were
competitive as things that are rolling
their way and you know things that they
were actually good at nobody takes her
true competitive person that things are
down like this to believe step up to the
playground glass roof I've never seen a
guy you know be able to flip the switch
from loose and laid-back to wanting to
absolutely kill somebody like he does
you know and not only does he just want
to win but he wants to just bury you
it's a story I tell many people it's a
par 4 they're a Wentworth and I hit it
about maybe two feet a foot and a half
behind the hole and heated on the back
edge and he putted it down and damn near
made his putt for birdie and so I threw
him his ball back and I just expected
him to give me my putt he turned his
back to me and started facing the 12th
tee so I looked around and I was about
five thousand or three thousand people
in the gallery and I didn't know what to
do and so I started to mark my ball and
I put my ball down I turned around and I
said tiger and he says Peter nice is
what I said he gave me this whole winter
I'll make sure let me remember that next
week
and he looked at me he says will you
ever want a hole yet have you and I'm
like whoa alrighty fine he's laughed on
the back again so I finally won my first
hole I walked back to when I said let me
tell you something pal I said if you
ever make me put a putt like that again
our friendship is over it's hard to
explain I guess it's just sport because
it's that's what we do that's what we we
have to do in order to win I'm not there
a tournament to to have fun and talk to
my buddies and enjoy being around them
I'm there to win the tournament now half
the term is over worth Hey let's go
party let's go have a great time you
know it's very important for me I'm
always competitive player and not just
in the games I'm in nutriyum like that
in your home with my sisters with my mom
with my nephews I'm always try to
competitive hearts and try to win unlike
that no I'm not I'm not I never change
because I like I like this I like what I
do I like my life I'm happy person so
computing is part of my life so in
Madeira and Madrid in England I wasn't
doing all this competitive person so as
part of me I was developing an unhealthy
contempt for Adidas you say or maybe it
was healthy I despised them yeah I'm
curious what you make of the competition
right now adidas is coming back from a
soft patch and they're upstarts like
Under Armour that are making a headway
on athletes and on sales well I think
I'm sort of a warrior by nature and so
everybody is a concern and but I'm still
the same as I was before I know they
asked me
and one of the rare TV interviews from
25 years ago if I wanted to meet the
president of Reebok and I said no I said
I don't know him I don't like him and I
don't want to like him and I still feel
that way about the competition
what about Under Armour in the US market
is there one agree they're one of them
they're there lots of them that we
compete with then but believe me we will
compete competitive if I tell Jim from
cousins Maine lobster I'm his picture
but you know I talked about him before
if I tell him one little thing about the
guy he used to compete with on the
hockey team Jim was a semi professional
hockey player had some injury or
something in the minor leagues if I'm
tell him that right but anyway his
archenemy on the other team was a guy
named Luke what do you think happened
Luke's for me
Jim's from Maine Luke went into the
lobster business all I have to do to
double sales say hey Jay here Luke
opened another restaurant talk about
competitive spirit he's ready to kill he
doesn't stop working he hates the idea
that somebody might beat him at a game
it says DNA and his partner savings the
same way all I have to do is tell Grace
& Lace who makes beautiful lacy socks
and shawls that are my most successful
business by far in terms of making money
and what do I have to do to get them
going hardly anything all I got to do is
a god got a big check from a cousin's
today you know I get a check from her
like within the week a bigger check
they're winning we're more successful
why I said compete with Merlin that's
the way they weren't competitive you get
an entrepreneur who doesn't feel the
heat of competition he's not gonna be
good on his feet she's not gonna come to
the fore when she really needs it that
competitive spirit drives you through
all the things that don't make any
common sense in life that's what it does
how much more do you need to be at your
absolute best okay you don't know when
you're gonna get there I think it key
thing is our trainer and you definitely
competition
you definitely are races in because I
over the years that training helps you
what you have to compete against other
people who are vile ever to help to
build you up to make you know what it
what else you need to work on in
training I think anyone if they're smart
and resourceful can like to use the
internet and use the resources that you
know that they have or that they create
for themself to do great things whatever
the magnitude of greatness is for you
you know just because I'm on a stage or
because I have a platform and wrote a
book doesn't mean that your level of
greatness is like any less than mine we
think that's important for people to
understand because we live in a culture
where celebrities are idolized and and I
talking in girlboss about being your own
Idol and competing with yourself I do my
best work when I compete with myself you
have to win here that that's the bottom
line is is what have you done lately you
know we've were able to accomplish a lot
of good things early on we've been in
the postseason every year so far but the
bottom line is when you're compete you
want to win and that's why your outfits
finishing second finish and third going
to a post season is not good enough I
think everyone should have that
mentality when you go into a season you
weren't a championship where it doesn't
mean anything have you always had that
kind of mentality even before you got to
New York or did it no question now I was
younger you know I always wanted my
daddies to beat me at everything we did
he wouldn't let you win oh yeah I
wouldn't let me win so now I don't let
anyone else win so uh you know I've
always had that mentality it's it's it's
it's pointless and from my point of view
if you're competing you don't win thank
you guys so much for watching I'd love
to know what you thought of the video
did you enjoy it did you not like it
which clip was your favorite what did
you learn from it how are you gonna now
be more competitive in your business in
your life leave it down in the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon